ANKUR KOTWAL: Welcome to part
four of the DevBytes series
Making Apps Beautiful.
Thus far, we've managed to make
our app look beautiful on
modern phones and tablets.
But we haven't really looked
at the performance aspect.
Having a beautiful app is more
than just how it looks when
it's not moving or animating.
It's about also making
sure that
it's smooth and jank-free.
So from a performance tuning
point of view, what I'd like
to do is to profile my device
on the lowest common
denominator, which is exactly
what we're going to do today.
We're going to use the Nexus S
running Android 2.3, fondly
known as Gingerbread.
So let's switch over to our
Nexus S, and see what our app
looks like in its
current state.
Bum bum.
It crashed.
Now, we're going to
switch back to the
slides and see why.
The reality of it is that
we're loading these
high-resolution mid images, and
then displaying them as
thumbnails.
So we're actually exhausting the
memory on the Nexus S much
sooner than we would on our
more modern devices.
And it would have even happened
with those ones if we
had more images.
So let's now switch to the code
and see how we can better
optimize this.
What we're going to do is load
these images at the resolution
that we're going to display
them, rather than their source
resolution.
So we use this BitmapFactory
Options object, and we set
this inJustDecodeBalance
to True.
What that does is it makes sure
that the code resources
only look at the metadata
of that bitmap.
And in this case,
the resolution.
So once we've loaded that, we're
going to go into our own
method, called calculate
inSampleSize.
We're going to try and calculate
what the value of
this should be.
Basically, inSampleSize
is a value that's used
like a power of two.
So inSampleSize of 1 will mean
we load the image in its
native resolution, or
source resolution.
Two will mean it'll be halved
horizontally and halved
vertically.
So it'll be a quarter of the
size of the original image.
So we just basically use some
basic arithmetic here to work
out, based on the source
resolution of the image versus
the display or required
resolution.
And then, based on that ratio,
we return this inSampleSize
from this method.
So scrolling back up, we've
calculated our inSampleSize,
passed it to our bitmap
factory option.
We then need to remember to
set inJustDecodeBounds to
False, and then go ahead
and load the
bitmap with our options.
So now that we've optimized
it and we're loading these
bitmaps in the resolution that
we need them in, let's go see
what it looks like
on the Nexus S.
Shouldn't crash this time.
There we go.
It launched.
And we can see the
apps running.
But it's not running great.
As we scroll here, you can
see that we're getting
some jitter and jank.
So let's look at how we can
optimize this, and let's
switch over to our slides
once again.
The reason that we're hitting
this jank is that we're
learning those images in the
main thread, in the UI thread.
And we really shouldn't
do that.
We should be doing these in
the background thread, and
then our friend the AsyncTask
object, class, is
going to help us.
So let's switch over
to some code again.
And we'll see here we've
got an AyncTask
for loading our bitmap.
We actually pass the image view
to this Async Task, and
we store it as a weak reference,
so that if the
framework needs to free that
image view, we're not going to
hold onto it, and we're
going to allow it
to be garbage collected.
Anyways, going to the
doInBackground method on our
AsyncTask, this is happening
in a background thread.
So we will go ahead
and actually
load our sample bitmap.
And this is that code
that we saw earlier.
So it will kick in with
those optimizations.
Once this is done, in
onPostExecute, we're just
going to go ahead and
apply the bitmap.
So now let's see how the app
looks like when we run it on
our Nexus S. Great.
We can see here that
as we scroll, the
images get loaded in.
And because they're doing it
in the background, what
happens is that we get
this placeholder.
It's just an empty image there,
until the image loads.
But it's happening in
the background.
And the important thing
is that our
scrolling is now smooth.
But we have a new problem now.
Every time an image goes off
the screen, we're actually
relinquishing that image.
We're freeing it and then
loading it back in.
That's not a very good
thing to do.
So what we're going to look
at is how to fix that.
So switching back to the slides,
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
an image cache.
Now, what an image cache does
is hold onto the images.
So we'll load the image, and
then we'll throw it into the
image cache.
And then we'll hold onto the
images for as long as it can.
And then when we go to request
an image, we're going to look
in the image cache first.
So let's switch over to code.
And in the onCreate method of
our fragment, what we're going
to do is initialize
our LIU cache.
That's the image cache
we're going to use.
But for the cache size, what
we're going to do is we're
going to set the cache size
based on the maximum available
memory on the device
for our app.
In kilobytes, so dividing
it by 1,024.
But we're actually going to
get 1/8 of that size.
So our cache should
be 1/8 of the
available memory, in kilobytes.
And that's what we will use to
initialize our LIU cache.
Also, keep in mind that we're
overriding the sizeOf method
so that we can tell the cache
how big our bitmaps
are going to be.
That's it.
With that, let's see what our
Nexus S looks like now.
So we're going to launch it.
We expect it to be nice and
smooth, which it is.
And what we're seeing here is
that as the images go off the
screen, they're not actually
being relinquished.
Our cache is kicking in.
Of course, if we blew our memory
limit, it would start
to dispose and throw away
of those images, and
load them if necessary.
But we don't need to
in this situation.
So we've reached the end
of this DevByte.
Let's switch over
to the slides.
This is where we started, on
the left-hand side, with an
outdated-looking app.
It now looks beautiful and
modern on modern devices.
It runs really well.
But one thing we haven't looked
at yet is how to make
it look equally beautiful
on all the devices.
And we're going to do that
in the next episode.